la frontière est ouverte et grand-père
Poutine dort pour toujours tous deux on
revendiqué l'attaque de lundi dans la
région de Belgorod
fort de centaines d'hommes selon leur
dire le corps des volontaires russes et
la Légion liberté de la Russie ont un
point commun ils veulent la chute de
Vladimir Poutine
nous sommes russes comme vous
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de place pour
la Russie de Vladimir Poutine pourri par
la corruption le mensonge la censure et
la restriction des libertés le corps des
volontaires russes est sorti du bois en
mars dernier une première incursion dans
la région frontalière de brillance sa
spécialité des actions de reconnaissance
et de sabotage sa volonté crée un nouvel
État national à partir des régions
majoritairement peuplées de Russes
à sa tête
dénisi figure de l'extrême droite en
Russie un terroriste aux yeux du Kremlin
le même terme est employé par Moscou
pour qualifier la Légion liberté de la
Russie
créée au printemps 2022 elle s'attaque
aux infrastructures militaires et
ferroviaires russes son but construit
une nouvelle Russie libre
une légion dirigée par un ancien député
russe il y a Ponomareff le seul au sein
de la Douma à avoir voté contre
l'annexion de la Crimée par le Kremlin
en 2014 il s'est depuis installé en
Ukraine
pour ce politologue les actions de ces
deux groupes ont un double impact
psychologique et militaire
le premier est d'ébranlé les Russes de
les inquiéter de la possibilité de
soulèvement au sein de leur propre
population
deuxièmement forcer les Russes à
disperser leurs troupes à déplacer
certains de leurs renfort vers la région
de Belgorod
en espérant que cela ouvre des brèches
pour l'Ukraine pour une attaque majeure
la question désormais ces hommes
sont-ils aidés militairement par
l'Ukraine oui selon il y a Ponomareff le
pouvoir ukrainien forme et fournit bien
des équipements à ces hommes même si
Kiev ne confirme pas préférant parler de
problèmes internes à la Russie
du côté du Kremlin on martèle le même
message ce ne sont pas des insurgés
russes mais bien des combattants
Ukrainiens proches du pouvoir